c'est le retour des astuces et
aujourd'hui on va parler de montage et
de musique est aussi voir comment la
musique peut justement mettre en valeur
vos vidéos mais ça ça sera juste après
l'intro non mais non non mais tu peux
pas me prendre c'est ma réplique ça du
nantes
[Musique]
hop
quoi
[Musique]
et salut à tous les amis c'est françois
pour la chaîne explique mans encore je
suis ravi de vous retrouver une nouvelle
fois sur cette chaîne on vous en a parlé
de cinq astuces que j'utilise qui
concerne la musique comme vous avez pu
le voir dans un extrait juste avant et
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que j'ai invité
sur cette vidéo nico de la chaîne tout
le monde peut faire de la musique
il est un peu spécial il va falloir
voilà mais vous allez voir il est sympa
quand même
mais avant de commencer je tiens à
préciser que ce sont des astuces que
j'utilise moi qui marche dans mon cas
mais il en existe plein plein plein et
surtout en ce qui concerne la musique on
peut faire vraiment beaucoup de choses
donc bah n'hésitez pas aussi à me dire
ce que vous en faites dans les
commentaires et c'est pas une obligation
de faire comme moi je vous partage juste
que ce que moi je fais et donc sans plus
attendre
commençons par la première astuce c'est
à dire marquer le bit
non mais t'as quel âge c'est ça qui te
fait rien non mais tu sais puisque ça te
fait rigoler qui va venir expliquer aux
gens tu vas aller vient de suite alors
le bit biat à ne pas confondre avec se
traduit en français par le mou
pulsations en fait c'est tous les coups
qu'on entend par exemple chez david
guetta les coups de grosse caisse ou
quand on fait du montage vidéo l'idée
c'est qu'on va essayer de repérer dans
la musique qu'on a choisi quelle est
cette pulsation quel est ce beat de
leurs s'en tire avec sa tête en secouant
ou avec son corps et à partir de là on a
calé les images le changement les
transitions en fonction du temps forts
du temps faibles etc
et sinon j'adore le truc mais c'est tout
doux et pour marquer le but visuellement
sur la timeline de notre logiciel de
montage on va pouvoir soit regardé les
pics soit on va pouvoir insérer
visuellement des marqueurs qui vont nous
permettre de monter beaucoup plus vite
et donc je vais commencer par prendre le
fichier audio qui sera la bande son de
ma vidéo et je vais utiliser un
raccourci tout bête c'est cela touche m
qui va permettre de poser des marqueurs
et là je vais commencer à compter le
temps et sur les seins et les trois dans
un deux trois quatre je vais taper sur
mon aide alors c'est un petit peu
fastidieux c'est un petit peu long ça
dépend du du morceau puisque une fois
que ce sera fait j'aurais plus qu'à
déposer mes morceaux de clips sur les
emplacements entre les marqueurs et ça
va être magnétique donc je veux juste à
ajuster comme ça mes petits clips pour
remplir ma timeline
passons maintenant à la deuxième astuce
c'est à dire modifier la structure de la
musique alors une fois qu'on a marqué la
pulsation et qu'on va pouvoir monter en
musique on va peut-être se rend compte
que la durée du morceau ne correspond
pas forcément aux pros
qu'on veut réaliser on peut avoir un
morceau qui fait 3 minutes 30 et ne
vouloir monter une vidéo que d'une
minute par exemple et la plupart des
éditeurs de vidéos permettent de
modifier la musique et on va voir ça
tout de suite
alors ici je vais garder le refrain de
la fin puisque le début ne m'intéresse
pas je vais environ une minute donc je
supprime le début le problème c'est
qu'il ya deux refrains et que c'est
encore un peu long donc je vais couper
ici et je vais garder juste la fin alors
je vais m'assurer être vraiment sûr que
ça s'enchaîne bien que c'est bien sûr le
premier temps de la mesure
voilà donc là je fais a justement un
petit peu plus fin et ensuite je vais
juste ajouter une transition fondus
enchaînés pour masquer les éventuels
petits petits défauts qui pourraient y
avoir sur la transition et faire que ça
passe tout seul
passons maintenant à la troisième
astuces on a découpé nos mesures en tout
en rythmes etc
mais on peut avoir l'effet inverse en
ayant quelque chose de trop régulier par
quelque chose qui sera pas forcément
hyper dynamique et pour ça on va
réaliser des quêtes sur les breaks
décote sur les breaks km toi t'es tu vas
et quand c'est à toi en plus moi je
t'appelle et même pas tu es concentré
namedji allée des yeux regarde les
lumières en plus alors un break en fait
qu'est ce que c'est ça a pour but de
structurer la musique la musique
elles marchent toujours par 4 par huit
par saez est en fait à chaque quatre
mesures 8 mesure où cette mesure ça
dépend des morceaux on va avoir ses
fameuses coupure souvent la quatrième
mesure la huitième mesure on va avoir
des choses qui vont accélérer le rythme
accéléré on va peut-être avoir envie de
calais nos images sur ce rythme-là effet
spécial donc ici en fait j'ai bien
marquer mais temps forts mais vous
pouvez voir que sur certains petit break
là des choses des grosses caisses des
caisses claires il y en a deux petits
qui s'enchaînent
enfin deux mesures et ensuite un gros à
la fin qui envoie ou à un moment où ça
pète terrible donc du coup j'ai fait ma
petite des coupes chez fellini et
marqueurs et j'ai mis mes fichiers est
alors sur les fichiers ce que vous
pouvez faire c'est utiliser comme cdd
passage super court tout ce qui est un
petit peu de déchet servira pas
forcément des plans raté mais les plans
les moins bons ils peuvent vraiment
servir à ce moment là pour donner du
dynamisme et vous permettre de faire des
breaks visuel quatrième astuce il faut
savoir qu'en vidéo comme en musique
parfois faut savoir mettre des silences
il ya des moments où un simple écran
noir comme ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec un cut ou avec un fondu ça vient
donner un rythme visuels supplémentaires
alors pour créer un vide pour créer un
espace noir c'est tout simple là je vais
juste me noter le passage de la musique
toujours avec des marqueurs qui
m'intéresse pour pouvoir placer ce vide
et là je vais utiliser un petit
raccourci que vous ne connaissez
peut-être pas option w qui va créer un
vide dans la timeline magnétique de
final cut est la cinquième et dernière
astuce c'est le sound design part je
vais pas vous refaire tout une vidéo là
dessus il ya déjà des choses très bien
fait notamment celle de julien fabre o 1
sur le sound design qui est vachement
sympa et qui explique très bien comment
ça fonctionne mais grosso modo ça va
être tous les petits effets sonores
qu'on va pouvoir rajouter par dessus la
musique par dessus la voie par dessus
les images pour donner plus de réalisme
à nos vidéos par exemple si vous filmez
des choses sur une plage vous pouvez
rajouter bruit des vagues et des
mouettes est ici dans l'exemple du début
quand je suis rentré dans la boutique
il n'y avait absolument pas de
clochettes et j'ai rajouté un bruit là
dessus ce qui donne un peu plus
d'ambiance à la vidéo quand j'ouvre la
porte j'ai rajouté non seulement la
petite cloche d'entrée mais aussi un
bruit de ville puisque boj avait pas
forcément de bruits d'ambiance et puis
se barber shop situé en ville donc j'ai
rajouté le petit bruit de ville qui va
bien pour donner cette impression la
meilleure en fait il y avait aucun sont
pris à ce moment là alors pour faire ça
vous pouvez soit sur le moment de votre
captation en capter avec un petit
enregistreur numérique soit allé
chercher sur des banques de sons sur
internet il ya plein de choses gratuites
qui sont super bien et qui marche très
très bien aussi et on peut s'en servir
d'ambiance mais aussi pour les
transitions avec notamment les bouches
sound je vous en mets des liens dans la
description vous allez voir ça c'est
super pratique pour les petits dont on
parlait dans la vidéo sur les
transitions mais que je vous met aussi
en lien dans la description et ça a
l'air de rien mais c'est un petit plus
au nord qui ajoutera à la personnalité
de votre vidéo
et voilà les amis c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui j'espère que cette vidéo
vous aura plu si c'est le cas n'hésitez
pas à mettre le tradition de plaster non
tu sors je disais donc le traditionnel
coup 2
blaster sur le pouce en l'air qui se
situe en dessous de cette vidéo vous
pouvez aussi vous abonner si ce n'est
pas déjà fait vous pouvez partager la
vidéo commenté eric et toussa toussa
toussa
n'hésitez pas aussi à aller faire un
tour sur la chaîne de nico qui s'appelle
tout le monde peut faire de la musique
c'est une chaîne qui est vachement bien
et puis moi je vous dis comme d'habitude
rester curieux et à très bientôt pour
une prochaine vidéo majeures au dessus
juste enlève là et là tu files là et la
lie la sas ans à la voix là il m'a
appris des accords je vais pas le faire
voilà bon on peut faire de la vue sont
allés voir sa chaîne c'est très bien
comme ça